THANKSGIVING?
>>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE
GROUP CHAT LIVE IN THE BLEACHER
LIV, WELCOME TO THE GROUP CHAT.
I NEED EVERYBODY, I NEED
EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND WELCOME LIV TO THE SHOW WITH
SOME SUN SETS.
YES.
SUN SETS.
THAT'S THE VIBES THAT WE LIKE
HERE ON THE GROUP CHAT, LIV.
WE LOVE SUN SETS.
EVERYONE AROUND HERE KNOWS
THOUGH, EVERYBODY KNOWS I'M A
WARRIOR FAN.
LIV, WE ALL WANT TO KNOW WHO IS
YOUR NBA TEAM?
>> IT'S KIND OF HIDDEN BEHIND
ME.
I AM BORN AND RAISED IN DENVER.
THEREFORE, I'M A DENVER NUGGETS
GIRL.
JO
JOKIC IS MY MVP.
BETTING ON YOUR TEAM CAN MAKE
YOU SAD SOMETIMES.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE NUGGETS
ARE INJURED SO MUCH THIS YEAR.
I'M A DENVER NUGGETS GIRL AND I
HAVE BEEN SINCE CARMELO ANTHONY
AND THE SILKY BLUE JERSEYS.
I LOVE THEM.
>> YOU ROCKING WITH THE HOME
TEAM.
I'M NOT MAD AT YOU.
I ROCK WITH MY HOME TEAM.
BUT, LIV, WE WANT TO KNOW.
WE HAVE TO KNOW, DO YOU BET WITH
YOUR HEART?
OR DO YOU BET WITH YOUR HEAD?
>> WELL, THE CORRECT ANSWER IS I
BET WITH MY HEAD.
THAT'S THE SMARTER ANSWER.
HOWEVER, WHEN I BET ON MY OWN
TEAM, I DEFINITELY BET WITH MY
HEART.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY PEOPLE TELL
YOU NOT TO DO THAT.
SO MAYBE I SHOULD LISTEN TO THAT
PIECE OF ADVICE.
BUT IT'S HARD NOT.
TO YOU ARE GET AN EMOTIONAL
TACHMENT TO THE TEAMS AND
PLAYERS.
IT IS SMARTER TO BET WITH YOUR
HEAD.
>> DON'T LISTEN TO THEM, LIV.
BET WITH YOUR HEART IF YOU WANT
TO.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
I BET WITH MY HEART AND DOING IT
TONIGHT.
SO ANYWAY, WE'RE EXCITED TO YOU
HAVE ON THE SHOW.
AND AS ALWAYS, AS ALWAYS, WE'RE
GIVING AWAY LOTS.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND
JERSEYS.
SO GET IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED GIFTS.
I NEED EMOJIS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, I NEED WINNERS
ONLY.
PLEASE, ACTUALLY, I NEED YOU
GUYS IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
PUT WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE.
LIV, I MAY AS WELL JUST GIVE
AWAY ONE RIGHT NOW.
WHY NOT?
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> LIV IS HERE.
FIRST SHOW.
SETTING THE VIBES.
IT'S A BUNCH OF SUN SETS IN THE
COMMENTS.
MY BOY LARRY HALVE FAME GOT A
SUNSET IN THE COMMENTS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
THE YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LOTS UNDERWATER HAS A SUNSET.
YOU ARE ALSO GETTING A HOODIE.
LIV, IT'S TNT TUESDAY.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
FAN DUEL IS BOOSTING THE THREE
BY TWO ON BOTH GAMES TONIGHT.
TONIGHT'S GAME, THE THREE BY TWO
CASH IN THE LAKERS-KNICKS GAME,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> A THREE GAME --
>> THERE IT S THE PASS.
FOR THREE?
YES.
THAT'S MONEY.
THAT'S THE OTHER 30.
THAT'S NOT STEPH CURRY.
THAT IS JULIUS RANDLE.
AND THAT RIGHT THERE IS
FOREIGNIER FROM THE CORNER FOR
THREE.
FORNIER.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER,
TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER
WHICH THREE BY TWO WILL CAST?
WE HAVE THE KNICKS TAKING ON THE
NETS.
WE GOT THE WARRIORS TAKING ON
THE SUNS.
LIV, HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
WOW.
THAT IS -- I MEAN --
>> BEHAVE SHOOTERS THAT -- WE DO
KNOW WE HAVE SHOOTERS IN THE
BODY SLATE.
BUT ALSO WE HAVE SHOOTERS IN THE
TOP SLATE IN THE EARLY GAME.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHICH THREE BY TWO IS A LOCK.
KEEP IN MIND THE KNICKS ARE
17-3.
LIVE, LET ME READ THAT AGAIN.
THE KNICKS ARE 17-7.
THAT IS A LITTLE NUGGET FOR YOU
GUYS.
LIVE, WHICH ONE OF THESE DO I
LIKE BEST?
THE WEST COAST SHOWDOWN OR EAST
COAST SHOWDOWN?
>> 17-3 IS HARD TO FADE.
IT IS ALSO HARD TO RIDE INTO THE
PUBLIC.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT WHAT
I'M ABOUT TO SAY RIGHT NOW.
HOWEVER, I LEAN WARRIORS AND
SUNS FOR THIS THREE BY.
TWO THE WARRIORS RANKED TOP
THREE FOR BOTH THREE POINTS
ATTEMPTED AND MADE.
NOT TO MENTION BOTH THE WARRIORS
AND SUNS HAVE A TOP TEN PACE.
I CAN SEE THIS KNICKS-NETS GAME
TAKING TIME TO WARM UP.
I THINK THIS WARRIORS-SUNS GAME
MAY COME OUT OF THE GATES HOT
FROM THE THREE.
YOU HAVE A GAME WITH CURRY,
COOL, BOOKER, CROWDER, WIGGINS.
IT'S JUST A RECIPE FOR A CASH.
I THINK ALL THOSE GUYS WILL BE
HOT FOR THE FROM THE THREE POINT
LINE.
I HAVE TO LEAN WARRIORS AND SUNS
IN THE THREE BY TWO.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M IN IN THE COMMENTS.
LOOKING UP TAKES.
THE I HAVE NICOLE SAYS WARRIORS
AND SUNS WITH CASH.
AND BECAUSE OF STEPH AND CURRY,
WINNERS ONLY SHOUTOUT TO YOU,
NICOLE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOOTIE.
MR. MACK 0011 SAYS GOT TO KEEP
IT ROLLING WITH THE KNICKS ON
THAT THREE BY TWO.
I DO LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THE KNICKS PLAY TOO.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHICH ONE
WE'RE RIDING AS A FAMILY, LIV.
WE'RE RIDING AS A FAMILY.
THE NEXT COMMENT, WE'RE JUST
GOING TO RIDE IT, OKAY?
WE'RE ALL GOING TO RIDE IT LIKE
ONE BIG HAPPY FAMILY.
RICHY 21 SAYS, WITH CURRY
PLAYING IT'S ALWAYS A LOCK.
LOCK IN GOLDEN STATE VERSUS
PHOENIX.
SO THEREFORE WE ARE RIDING
TOGETHER AS A FAMILY.
WE'RE RIDING TOGETHER WITH THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS TAKING ON
THE PHOENIX SUNS.
BUT WHY NOT SPRINKLE MONEY ON
THE FIRST LATE OF GAMES TOO?
THE NEW YORKUP.
SPRINKLE MONEY ON IT.
BET BOTH THREE BY TWOS.
WHY NOT?
LET'S GET RICH.
WE ASKED YOU GUYS IN THE APP.
WE ASKED YOU ON THIS BLEACHER
REPORT APP THAT IT YOU ARE
WATCHING THE SHOW, HOW MANY
POINTS WILL STEPH CURRY SCORE
TONIGHT?
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT YOU THINK.
AT THE END OF THE GAME, WE'LL DM
ONE RANDOM PERSON THAT GETS
CLOSEST AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
THE LINE IS CURRENTLY SET AT
29 1/2.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU LIKE THAT NUMBER?
>> I DO LIKE THAT NUMBER.
I MEAN, LISTEN.
STEPH CURRY TEED UP A REF WHEN
HE KNOCKED DOWN A THREE POINTER
THE OTHER NIGHT.
IF HE DOES NOT SCARE YOU RIGHT
NOW OR SCARE YOU THIS YEAR,
WE'RE WATCHING TWO COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT NBA CHANNELS.
THIS MAN IS SCARY TO ME RIGHT
NOW.
NOT TO MENTION THE SUNS ARE
ALLOWING AN AVERAGE OF 23 POINTS
PER GAME TO THE OPPOSING POINT
GUARD POSITION.
AND IT FEELS DISRESPECTFUL TO
PUT STEPH CURRY IN THE SAME
CATEGORY AS THE AVERAGE POINT
GUARD IN THIS LEAGUE.
HE IS DIFFERENT.
I THINK GAME IS A SHOOTOUT.
I THINK STEPH EASILY DROPS A 30
PE
PIECE TONIGHT.
>> YES, LIV.
I LOVE YOUR TAKE.
I LOVE THE TAKE.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT STEPH CURRY.
THE GUY HAS BEEN ON A MISSION.
HIS MISSION IS TO WIN THE MVP
THIS YEAR.
BARRING INJURY, I THINK STEPH,
HE'S DONE ENOUGH TO ME.
I MEAN HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DO IT.
THE GUY HAS BEEN REMARKABLE.
HE'S BEEN REMARKABLE.
IF HE CONTINUES TO DO WHAT HE'S
BEEN DOING, BARRING INJURY, HE
SHOULD BE THE MVP THIS YEAR.
BUT, LIV, STEPH, GETS 30.
THAT'S LIKE A LAY-UP FOR HIM.
THAT'S EASY.
GO GET 30, STEPH.
LIKE THAT SHOULD BE EASY.
I'M TAKING THE OVER.
BUT LET ME HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS.
LET ME HOP INTO THESE COMMENTS.
I GOT MAD DODGER IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, MATT DODGER.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT -- THE COMMENTS ARE ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
I GOT -- ANUK SAYS HE WILL HIT
NINE THREE POINTERS.
WOW.
THAT IS A VERY, VERY, VERY BOLD
STATEMENT.
BUT IT'S STEPH CURRY.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE PROBABLY --
STEPH CURRY.
HE HAS A CHANCE AT DOING IT.
I HAVE YOUNG SKOL YOU ARE ALL
WALKING AWAY WITH HOODIES.
PLEASE REMEMBER AFTER THE GAME
WE'RE GOING TO HIT UP ONE PERSON
AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A JERSEY.
NOW LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS,
MONEY LINES AGAINST THE SPREAD
AND POINTS TOTAL FOR TONIGHT'S
GAME, LIV.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS, LIV.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING HERE?
AND WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> RIGHT OFF THE BAT, I LIKE
OVER 221 1/2 IN THE
WARRIORS-SUNS MATCHUP.
THESE TWO TEAMS RANKED TOP FIVE
IN POINTS SCORED PER GAME.
ONE OF THOSE TEAMS, THE
WARRIORS, ARE LEADING THE LEAGUE
IN THREE POINTERS MADE.
AND LIKE I SAID EARLIER, TWO TOP
TEN PACE TEAMS.
I THINK STHIS IS A SHOOTOUT.
SO RIGHT OFF THE BAT, I LIKE THE
OVER IN THE WARRIORS-SUNS
MATCHUP.
>> LOVE THAT.
LOVE THAT, LIV.
ACTUALLY, WE KNOW THE HIGH
POWERED OFFENSE IN GOLDEN STATE.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING
THIS YEAR.
WE ALSO KNOW THE SUNS HAVE A
GOOD TEAM.
THEY LIKE TO SHOOT THE BALL IN
PHOENIX.
I DON'T DISLIKE YOUR OVER THERE,
LIV.
I DO NOT DISLIKE YOUR OVER.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS
BRING GIVE MY TAKE.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
HERE WE GO.
SOCIAL DILEMMA, SOCIAL DILEMMA
SAYS, HE SAYS STEPH IS GOING FOR
34.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
I MEAN, EVEN THOUGH WE MOVE PAST
THAT, I'M GIVING YOU A HOODIE
JUST BECAUSE OF THE TAKE.
I LOVE THE TAKE.
I GOT THE WARRIORS PLUS 3 1/2.
BIG BRY GUY SAYS FREE CASH FOR
THE WARRIORS PLUS 3 1/2.
LOCKS UNDER WATER SAYS 25 FOR
THE JERSEY BUT WE'RE NOT FROM
NEW JERSEY.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT MEANS.
OH, I GUESS HE SAYS STEPH IS
GOING FOR 25 POINTS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU LOTS UNDER
WATER.
LET ME JUMP IN HERE, LIV.
THIS LINE KEEPS GROWING.
IT KEEPS GROWING.
IT KEEPS -- I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I HAVE NO REASON WHY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THIS WARRIORS
PLUS 3 1/2.
I DON'T WANT THE PLUS 3 1/2.
I WANT THE MONEY LINE.
THE WARRIORS THEY'VE BEEN
PLAYING WELL.
THEY'VE BEEN PLAYING REALLY
WELL.
THEY'VE BEEN PLAYING EXTREMELY
THE BEST TEAM IN THE NBA, LIV.
I DON'T SEE WHY THEY'RE THE JUPD
DOG.
I KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO PHOENIX.
I KNOW THAT THEY'RE -- IT'S
GOING TO BE A HOSTILE PLAY-OFF
LIKE ENVIRONMENT.
BUT PLUS 3 1/2?
I CAN SEE THIS.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE A PICK
THEM OR SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW LIKE VALUE.
AND ALSO, I'M BETTING WITH MY
HEART.
I'M TAKING THE WARRIORS ON THE
MONEY LINE.
WE TALKED MAJOR MARKETS.
NOW LET'S TALK SOME PLAYER
PROPS, LIV.
LET'S HOP INTO IT.
WE LIKE TO PLAY A LITTLE GAME
CALLED LOCK OR NOT?
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP IN
THE AUDIENCE.
I WANT THE AUDIENCE TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF IT'S
A LOCK OR IT'S NOT.
LIV, ARE YOU READY?
>> I AM READY.
I WAS BORN READY.
>> I LIKE THAT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT THEN.
FIRST UP IS K.D. TO SCORE OVER
28 1/2 POINTS IN TONIGHT'S
NETS-KNICKS MATCHUP.
THE ODDS ARE KERNCURRENTLY AT M
106.
LIV, IS THAT A LOCK OR NOT.
>> I'M GOING WITH NOT.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SAY
KEVIN DURANT.
I MEAN HE IS ARGUABLY THE
STRONGEST SCORERS IN THE LEAGUE
RIGHT NOW.
MAYBE EVEN THE BEST.
HOWEVER, THIS NETS TEAM, YOU GOT
SOME GUYS THAT ARE KIND OF
FINDING THEIR GROOVE RIGHT NOW.
PATTY MILLS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE.
I FEEL LIKE HE HAS FILLED THE
JOE HARRIS SHOES FROM THE THREE
POINT LINE.
AND THAT TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF
THE PRESSURE OFF KD IN A GAME
LIKE THIS.
ALSO, LAMARCUS ALDRIDGE IS THE
CENTER.
AND HE'S GOING UP AGAINST A TEAM
ON THE KNICKS THAT THEIR CENTER
RIGHT NOW IS QUESTIONABLE.
THEY HAVE A QUESTIONABLE
ROBINSON.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALDRIDGE WHO
IS SCORING DECENTLY LATELY TO
GET SOME BUCKETS.
SO BECAUSE OF GUYS LIKE MILLS
AND BECAUSE OF GUYS LIKE
ALDRIDGE TONIGHT, I THINK
THEY'VE GOT MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO SCORE.
AND I THINK IT TAKES A LITTLE
PRESSURE OFF KD.
NOT TO SAY WON'T HAVE HIMSELF A
GAME.
THAT'S A PRETTY HIGH NUMBER.
HE HITS IT A LOT.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE HAS TO DO ALL
OF THE SCORING WORK TONIGHT.
I'M ACTUALLY LEANING ON THE
UNDER.
>> LIV THAT, IS A VERY, VERY
INTERESTING TAKE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT KEVIN
DURANT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE BEST
PLAYER IN THE NBA.
ALSO, LIV THIS IS THE NEW YORK
MATCHUP.
THE KNICKS TAKING ON THE NETS.
THE CELEBRITIES ARE GOING TO BE
THERE.
NATIONALLY TELEVISED GAME.
YOU DON'T THINK KD IS GOING TO
SHOW UP?
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKETS?
K.D. IS GOING TO SHOW UP.
HE'S GOING TO PUT UP -- I SAY
HE'S GOING OVER 30.
I THINK HE IS GOING OVER 30.
HE JUST HAD 39 IN THE LAST GAME,
LIV.
THAT HOT HAND?
THAT HOT HAND OF KEVIN DUR SANT
GO
-- DURANT IS GOING TO TRANSFER
OVER INTO THIS BIG GAME IN NEW
YORK.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS THOUGH.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING.
I HAVE MR. PANCAKES.
HE'S IN THE COMMENTS SAYING,
K.D. IS GOING FOR 40E.
BET WITHOUT IT.
HE'S GOING BET ANYBODY.
MR. MACK 0011 SAYS 40E PIECE FOR
K.D.
HE LOVES TO COOK THE KNICKS.
YES, THIS IS THE NEW YORK
MATCHUP, LIV.
K.D. IS GOING TO SHOW UP.
I HAVE ONE MORE.
I GOT ONE MORE.
SHOUTOUT TO SAUCE, HE SAYS KEVIN
DURANT IS DROPPING 30 POINTS.
NEXT IS PATTY MILLS.
YOU MENTIONED PATTY MILLS.
YOU MENTION THAT HE'S BEEN
STEPPING UP.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT PATTY MILLS.
HIS THREE POINTS MADE IS SITTING
AT OVER OR UNDER 3 1/2?
DO YOU THINK THE OVER IS A LOCK
OR NOT?
I THINK IT'S A LOCK.
PATTY MILLS HIT THIS OVER IN
FOUR OF THE LAST FIVE.
LIKE I SAID, HE'S REALLY FINDING
HIS GROOVE FROM THE THREE POINT
LINE.
AND NOT TO MENTION, HE'S GOING
UP AGAINST THE KNICKS TEAM THAT
CURRENTLY ALLOWS THE FIFTH MOST
THREE POINTERS TO THEIR
OPPONENT.
THE PERIMETER DEFENSE HAS BEEN
THEIR DOWN FALL THIS YEAR.
I THINK HE HAS NO PROBLEM IN
THIS NEW YORK MATCHUP.
I'M TERRIFIED OF THE UNDER FOR
KEVIN DURANT.
YOU CONVINCED ME ALMOST OUT OF
IT.
BUT PATTY MILLS WILL THRIVE
AGAINST A KNICKS TEAM THAT
STRUGGLES TO DEFEND THE
PERIMETER.
I LOVE IT.
P IT'S A LOCK.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DISAGREE
WITH YOU ON THIS ONE.
I'M GOING TO RIDE TO YOUR VIBES
AND PATTY MILLS HAS BEEN BALLING
LATELY.
HE HAS BEEN BALLING.
I CAN SEE HIM MAKE THREES.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS AND
SEE WHAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I HAVE WM BOLD SAYING THE UNDER.
DON'T LIKE THOSE VIBES.
ME AND LIV ARE GOING WITH THE
OVER.
GUESS WHAT?
STILL GOING TO GIVE YOU A
HOODIE.
IT'S THE HOLIDAYS, WHY NOT?
VINSO'NEAL 68 SAYS HAS TO BE
OVER IF THE NETS WANT TO WIN.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
OF THE NETS WANT TO WIN, PATTY
MILLS HAS TO SHOW UP.
SHOUTOUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
LIV, FINALLY, JULIUS RANDLE AT
OVER 30 1/2 COMBINED POINTS AND
REBOUNDS.
LIV, THE OVER -- THE OVER IS IT
A LOCK OR IS IT NOT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, LOOK AT THAT
PICTURE OF HIM.
I'D BE SCARED TO TRY TO GO UP
AGAINST THIS GUY AND GET
REBOUNDS.
HE IS LOOKING FIT THIS YEAR.
MY GOSH.
BUT ONE OF MY FAVORITE BETS LAST
SEASON ESPECIALLY IN THE
PLAYOFFS WAS JULIUS RANDLE TO
GET SOME REBOUNDS.
TYPICALLY, YOU KNOW, YOU LEAN ON
HIS POINTS BECAUSE HE'S KIND OF
THE DOMINANT SCORER.
OR HE WAS ANYWAY LAST YEAR FOR
THIS KNICKS TEAM.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE A QUESTIONABLE
STARTER FOR THE CENTER POSITION
ON THIS KNICKS TEAM.
THAT RIGHT THERE GIVES THEM MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET BOARDS AND
HE'S GOING AGAINST A NETS TEAM
THAT RANKED BOTTOM TEN IN
REBOUNDS ALLOWED TO THE
OPPONENT.
I DON'T WORRY ABOUT HIS ABILITY
TO SCORE IN A GAME LIKE THIS.
A LOT OF TYPE AROUND THIS GAME.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE PLAY GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITIES HE HAS TO GET
BOARDS TONIGHT AS WELL.
I'M TAKING THE OVER.
THE I THINK IT'S A LOCK.
>> LIV IS TAKING THE OVER.
I ACTUALLY LIKE THAT, LIV.
WE CALL JOOUT JULIUS RANDLE ON
THIS SHOW, WE CALL HIM THE OTHER
30.
WE NO HE WHO 30 IS.
THAT IS 30, STEPH CURRY, YES.
BUT ON THE EAST COAST, HE'S THE
30 OUT THERE.
HE IS DESERVEDLY SO TO BE CALLED
THE 30 OUT THERE IN THE EAST
COAST.
WE KNOW, WE KNOW THE REBOUNDS
WILL BE THERE, LIKE YOU SAID.
HE'S BEEN STRUGGLING TO SCORE
LATELY.
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
IT'S THE BIG NEW YORK MATCHUP.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO GET MY
GUY JULIUS RANDLE TO SCORE MORE
POINTS TONIGHT.
HE'S GOING HAVE TO ANSWER THE
CALL.
ANSWER THE BELL.
IT IS NEW YORK VERSUS NEW YORK.
WHO IS GOING TO RUN THE CITY?
JULIUS.
IT'S UP YOU TO, MAN.
GO GET SOME POINTS.
YOU HAVE TO SCORE TODAY.
IF HE SCORES, YOU KNOW THE
REBOUNDS ARE THERE.
I LIKE THE OVER.
I'M IN HAD THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
GIVING AWAY ONE HOODIE.
>> LOCALITY ME SEE.
RANDAL IS LIKELY TO GO OVER
ADJUSTMENT IN POINTS.
BIG GAME TONIGHT.
SHOUTOUT YOU TO WESTBROOK 34.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU JAY HERN, YOU'RE
WALK AGO WAY WITH A HOODIE.
LIV, LET'S MOVE ON.
WE LOVE THE PARLAY AROUND HERE.
SO BE OUR BILLS ACCUSTOM --
ACCUSTOM ONE FOR EVERYBODY.
AND YOU GUYS CAN RIDE ALONG WITH
US.
SO I'M GOING TO TELL WHAT YOU
WE'RE LOOKING AT.
I WANT TO HEAR YOUR TAKE IN THE
COMMENTS.
THEN TONIGHT ON INSIDE THE NBA
PREGAME SHOW, CHUCK, YES, CHUCK
CHARLES BARKLEY IS GOING TO LOOK
AT OUR PARLAY AND PICK HIS
FAVORITE LEG.
LAST WEEK WE HIT THREE OF FOUR
LEGS AND MISSED.
THEY DECIDED TO BENCH THE R.J.
BARRETT.
WE NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
FOR.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE UP ONE
THIS WEEK, LIV.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE UP ONE THIS
WEEK.
BUT BEFORE -- BEFORE WE GET INTO
IT, I NEED EVERYONE IN THE
COMMENTS TO TELL ME WHAT THEY
THINK OF THE PARLAY, WHICH LEG
IS GOING TO LOSE THE PARLAY,
WHICH LEG IS THE LOCK OF THE
PARLAY.
JUST GIVE ME TAKES ON THE PARLAY
AND, LIV, GUESS WHICH TEAM THE
SAME GAME PARLAY IS ON TONIGHT.
LET'S GET RIGHT IT TO.
STARTING IT OFF.
WE CALL HIM 30 ON THIS SHOW.
30, WE NEED YOU TO GET FIVE
THREE POINTERS.
THIS IS LIKE A LAY-UP FOR STEPH
CURRY.
HE DOES THIS IN HIS SLEEP
NIGHTLY HE MAKES FIVE THREES.
I'M PRETTY SURE.
HE GOES OUT ON TO THE COURT AND
MAKES FIVE THREES LIKE IT'S
NOTHING.
LIKE IT'S NOTHING.
SO, LIVE, TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS LEG OF THE
PARLAY OR DO YOU NOT?
>> OF COURSE I DO.
I MEAN, STEPH CURRY FIVE PLUS
MADE THREES.
HE HIT THIS IN THE LAST THREE.
IT FEELS WRONG TO EVER FADE
STEPH CURRY FROM THE THREE POINT
LINE.
ESPECIALLY IN A GAME LIKE.
THIS THIS IS A MATCHUP WE'LL SEE
IN THE WESTERN CONFERENCE
CHANGE-UP GAME.
HE'S GOING TO SHOW OUT.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THIS PLAY.
.
THERE IS NO REASON THIS
SHOULDN'T HIT.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
THE I SEE -- I'M SENSING THE
GOOD VIBES.
I'M SENSING THE GOOD VIBES.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
MY GUY D-BOOK.
D-BOOK, 20 POINTS.
LIV, YOU MENTIONED HIGH SCORING.
YOU MENTIONED SHOOTOUT.
CAN DBOOK GET 20 TONIGHT?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS A GAME THAT DEVIN BOOKER
IS GOING TO SHOW UP TO AND DO
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO.
.
>> I CAN SEE THIS PROP CASHING
IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
I HAVE NO WORRIES ABOUT DEVIN
BOOKER GETTING 20 PLUS POINTS AT
ALL, ESPECIALLY IN A GAME LIKE
TONIGHT.
>> LOVE THAT TAKE.
WITH THE SAME GAMES PARLAY, THE
EARLIER BETS THAT YOUR BET HITS,
THE BETTER.
YOU GET TO ENJOY THE REST OF THE
GAME.
I LOVE THE THIRD QUARTER.
I LOVE THASHGTS LIV.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LEG
THOUGH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LEG.
WE TALKED CURRY.
WE TALKED D-BOOK.
LET'S MOVE ON TO CHRIS PAUL.
I WAS KIND OF SKEPTICAL WITH
THIS ONE.
I'M NOT GOING TO LICHLT BUT,
LIV, TALK TO ME.
GIVE ME GOOD VIBES.
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK OF CHRIS
PAUL GOING FOR TEN ASSISTS
TONIGHT.
TEN OR PLUS ASSISTS TONIGHT.
>> THIS ONE DOES MAKE ME
NERVOUS.
I DON'T HATE IT AT ALL.
THE HARD THING ABOUT CHRIS PAUL,
HE IS HARD TO GET A READ ON.
SOMETIMES HE IS FOCUSING ON
SCORING.
OTHER TIMES HE'S FOCUSED ON
FACILITATING THE OFFENSE.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO GET FROM THIS GUY.
I MEAN IT'S TOUGH TO GET A READ
ON WHAT HE'S GOING TO BRING TO A
GAME LIKE TONIGHT.
BUT THERE IS NO REASON IT
SHOULDN'T HIT.
HE HIT THIS OVER IN THREE OF THE
LAST FIVE.
AND HE IS THE POINT GUARD.
SO HIS JOB IS TO FACILITATE THE
OFFENSE.
AND TO FEED THE BALL TO A GUY
LIKE DEVIN BOOKER SO HE CAN HIT
20 PLUS POINTS.
SO HOPEFULLY HE DOES HIS JOB
CORRECTLY.
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
IT.
>> OKAY.
YEAH.
YOU SEE, LIKE I SEE DOTS HERE.
J
JUST SEE DOTS AND THEY'RE
CONNECTING EACH TIME.
LIV IS TELLING ME MY PARLAY IS
GOING TO HIT.
I LIKE IT.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS LAST LEG.
DRAYMOND GREEN.
NOW, LIV, DRAYMOND, HE'S
ALMOST -- WOINT CALL HIM A
WALKING TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
BUT HE IS ALMOST A WALKING
TRIPLE WILL DOUBLE WHAT DO YOU
THINK THIS?
THIS IS LOW FOR DRAY MOPPED.
I THINK HE CAN GET THIS EASY.
>> DRAYMOND IS NOT THE TYPE OF
GUY I WOULD STICK IN THE THREE
POINT LINE AND DEPEND ON HIM TO
SCORE.
BECAUSE I THINK IS A FAST PACED
GAME, I THINK HE NEEDS TO FOCUS
ON DEFENSE.
HE HIT THIS OVER IN THREE OF THE
LAST FIVE.
I HAVE ALWAYS SAID WHEN DRAYMOND
GREEN PRIORITIZES SOMETHING THAT
IS NOT SCORING, WHETHER IT BE
ASSISTS OR REBOUNDS OR BLOCKS OR
STEALS, HE IS SO DANGEROUS.
THE SECOND I FEEL LIKE HE STARTS
PRIORITIZING SCORING, I THINK HE
LOSES THE DANGER ABOUT HIM.
SO HE NEEDS TO STAY UNDER THE
BASKET.
GRAB THE BOARDS AND BE A
DOMINANT FORCE ON DEFENSE.
>> LIV IS FEELING THE PARLAY AND
MY BET.
MY WARRIORS WIN MONEY LINE.
SO I'M FEELING THE VIBES, LIV.
I AM FEELING THE VIBES.
I'M FEELING GOOD.
LET'S PULL THIS TICKET UP.
WE HAVE TO SEE HOW MUCH MONEY
WE'RE GOING TO WIN WHEN WE PUT
THIS DOWN.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT $100 DOWN AND
WALK WITH 44$446.
THAT IS $400 AND CHANGE RIGHT
THERE, LIV.
GRADE OUR PARLAY.
BEFORE I GET IN THE COMMENTS,
WHAT ARE YOU GRADING THE BR
BETTING PARLAY?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO GIVE
IT A SOLID A MINUS.
THE ONLY REASON I'M NOT GIVING
IT AN A PLUS IS BECAUSE I
EXPLAINED THAT IT'S HARD TO GET
A READ ON A GUY LIKE CHRIS PAUL.
HE'LL GIVE US ONE OR THE OTHER
SOMETIMES.
SCORING OR ASSISTS.
TONIGHT WE NEED THE ASSISTS.
st SO IF HE CAN SHOW UP, I'M
GOING TO FEEL REALLY GOOD.
A MINUS BECAUSE OF THAT ONE
ASSIST PROP THAT IS MAKING ME
TINY BIT NERVOUS.
OTHERWISE IT'S A SOLID PARLAY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A VERY SOLID
GAME TONIGHT.
THE I BELIEVE IT.
>> YES, I LOVE THE VIBES, LIV.
I'M FILLED WITH SUN SETS IN MY
HEART BECAUSE OF THE VIBES OF
THIS SHOW.
I FEEL LIKE I'M GOING TO WIN
EVERY BET TONIGHT.
LET'S GO.
THE YOU HAVE TO MANIFEST IT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES, LIV.
I'M GIVING AWAIVE A JERSEY HERE.
SO I'LL GIVE AWAY THE JERSEY
FIRST.
AND I SEE MONEY LINE KILLERS.
MONEY LINE KILLER SAYS EASY
MONEY RIGHT THERE.
BOOKER CAN GET 24 POINTS EASILY.
SHE IS RIDING WITH OUR PARLAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU MONEY LINE
KILLER.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
I'M NOT DONE IN THE COMMENTS.
BECAUSE I WANT TO GIVE AWAY MORE
HOODIES.
I GOT -- I HAVE SOCIAL DILEMMA.
SOCIAL DILEMMA IS IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING HE IS SAYING
HE'S ROCKING WITH OUR PARLAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, SOCIAL DILEMMA.
I HAVE CJ PRINCE, I'M IN LIV,
PARLAY LOOKS GOOD.
CP, MAY BE TOUGH.
I'M WITH YOU, LIV.
SO C.P. ASSIST MAY BE TOUGH.
BUT THE PARLAY LOOKS GOOD.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU C.J. PRINCE.
I GOT ONE MORE.
J.J. MARK 1030 SAYS MANIFESTING
THE HOODIE RIGHT NOW.
THE GUESS WHAT, BROTHER, YOU
MANIFEST IT CORRECTLY.
BECAUSE YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
LIV, YOU SEE HOW IT GOES ON OUR
SHOW?
THEY MENTION YOU, THEY GET WHAT
THEY WANT.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE JUST IN A GIVING
MOOD RIGHT HERE.
MUCH IT'S THE HOLIDAYS.
WHY NOT?
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS,
LIV.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
PHOENIX SUNS TEAM.
BUT THE SUNS ARE CURRENTLY ON
THE 16 HUFF GAME WINNING STREAK.
BUT THEY'RE THE FOURTH FAVORITE
TO WIN THE NBA FINALS.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF THE
PHOENIX SUNS CAN WIN IT ALL.
IF NOT, TELL ME WHICH TEAM YOU
THINK IS GOING TO GO ALL THE
WAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
PHOENIX CURRENTLY SITTING AT
PLUS 900, LIVS THAT GOOD VALUE?
>> I'LL START WITH THE SUNS AND
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S GOOD VAL
UCHLT THE SUNS ARE HOT RIGHT
NOW.
THE I HAVE A HOT TAKE TO
ACCOMPANY THEM BEING HOT RIGHT
NOW.
THEY'RE A GOOD TEAM.
THEY'RE SOLID TEAM.
WE SAW THIS LAST SEASON IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
THEY'RE A YOUNG TWEEM A LOT OF
TALENT.
THAT IS THE PLAY-OFF PRESSURE.
WHEN IT COMES TO PLAYOFFS AND
REALLY MAKING A DEEP RUN, IT'S
THOSE VETERANS THAT ALWAYS COME
OUT ON TOP THIS WARRIORS TEAM IS
ALLOWING THE FEWEST POINTS ON
THEIR OPPONENT.
THEY'RE DANGEROUS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE BALL.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FULL TEAM
KOURNT YET F THAT DOESN'T
TERRIFY YOU FOR THE POTENTIAL OF
THIS WARRIORS TEAM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL.
I HAVE TO RIDE WITH THE WARRIORS
AT PLUS 600 RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T THINK THE SUNS HAVE WHAT
IT TAKES JUST YET IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY CAN DO IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
THEY'VE GOT THE TALENT.
THEY NEED THAT CHEMISTRY.
THEY NEED THAT MATURITY TO HAND
THAT WILL PRESSURE.
AND I DON'T THINK THEY'RE THERE
YET.
I DO THINK THE WARRIORS ARE
THERE.
SO I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
WARRIORS AT PLUS 600.
>> LOVE YOUR TAKE, LIV.
LOVE YOUR TAKE.
I KNOW THIS IS YOUR FIRST SHOW.
THE VERY FIRST SHOW OF LAST
SEASON, WE HAD THE SAME
QUESTION.
WHO WOULD WIN IT ALL THIS
SEASON?
AND, LIV, I GAVE THE PEOPLE PLUS
1200.
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO WE ASKED THE
SAME QUESTION.
THEY ASKED US, WHO IS GOING TO
WIN THE NBA FINALS?
AND ONCE AGAIN, I GAVE THE
PEOPLE THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
AND NOW TODAY, LIV, YOUR FIRST
SHOW HERE, WE'RE SO THANKFUL TO
HAVE YOU.
THEY'RE ASKING US THIS QUESTION
AGAIN.
WHO SHOULD BE FAVORITE TO WIN IT
ALL?
WHO IS GOING TO WIN?
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS IS WHO
I'M PICKING.
LIV, YOU MENTIONED IT.
THE RICH IS GETTING RICHER.
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE MOST HIGH
POWERED OFFENSES IN THE LEAGUE.
AND THEY'RE JUST GOING TO GET
BETTER WHEN CLAY THOMPSON AND
JAMES WISEMAN COP COME TO JOIN
THE TEAM.
I'M WITH THE WARRIORS, MAN.
IF IT AIN'T BROKE, DON'T FIX IT.
I TOLD YOU AT THE GIPG OBEGINNI
THIS SVENLT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ROCK WHAT THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS TO WIN THIS
YEAR'S CHAMPIONSHIP.
BUT LET ME HOP IN THE COMMENTS,
LIV.
I HAVE TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT IN THE
COMMENTS.
I HAVE END EVERYMAN.
STRENGTH IN NUMBERS.
THAT MEAN HE IS ROCKING WITH THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
J.J. MARK 1030 SAYS WARRIORS WIN
BECAUSE STEPH IS THE BEST PLAYER
ON THE FLOOR.
UNGUARDABLE.
WINNERS ONLY.
MANIFESTING A JERSEY.
COME BACK NEXT WEEK.
LOI LOV
LOVE THAT TAKE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
THE SUNS.
ROCKING WITH THE SUNS.
I LOVE THAT TAKE.
I DON'T LOVE THE TAKE.
BUT I RESPECT I THE TAKE.
IT'S DIFFERENT FROM WHAT ME AND
LIV SAID.
THAT'S WHY I SPREKRESPECT IT.
I HAVE ONE MORE IN ME.
MONEY MUNCHER, PHOENIX CANNOT
MAKE IT PAST THE WARRIORS WHO
WILL TAKE IT ALL THE WAY.
CLAY IS COMING BACK AND HE WILL
SEAL THE DEAL.
SO SHOUTOUT TO YOU MONEY MUNCHER
10.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, I THINK IT'S TIME TO GET ON
UP OUT OF HERE, LIV.
THANK YOU GUYS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAPPING INTO THE GROUP CHAT
PRESENTED BY FAN DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE THREE BY TWO.
MUCH IT'S A LOCK.
WE'RE SPRINKLING IT ON BOTH
GAMES.
STEPH OVER IS EASY.
THAT THING IS CASH.
AND STEPH CURRY, IT'S ONLY
SITTING AT 29 1/2.
STEPH CURRY.
GET ON FAN DUEL.
TELL OUR SAME GAME PARLAY.
LIV LOVES IT.
TELL OUR SAME GAME PARLAY AND
TUNE INTO TONIGHT'S PREGAME SHOW
TO SEE CHUCK PICK HIS FAVORITE
LEG ON OUR PARLAY.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK GIVING
OUT MORE HOODIES AND JERSEYS AND
MORE LOCKS AND IF YOU WON A
HOODIE TODAY, IF YOU WON A
JERSEY TODAY, B/R BETTING WILL
DM YOU.
THANKS TO LIV FOR BRINGING HER A
GAME TO I D.A. THANK YOU TO
A-GAME FOR BRINGING HER A-GAME
TO I D.A. I'M FEELING GENEROUS.
IT'S THE CHRISTMAS COLORS.
DECEMBER IS COMING.
IT'S -- I THINK IT'S TOMORROW.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY ANOTHER
HOODIE.
I'M JUST GOING TO.
I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE AWAY.
I SEE EDDIE ON THE GO.
EDDIE, SEASON OF GIVING.
EDDIE ON THE GO SAYS WARRIORS
VERSUS BUCKS AND THE WARRIORS
TAKING IT ALL.
SHOUTOUT YOU TO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TAKE.
THANK YOU FOR STICKING AROUND
UNTIL THE END.
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
STICK AROUND UNTIL THE END?
YOU WILL BE REWARDED.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS GET ON FAN
DUEL AND RIDE US WITH, FOLLOW US
ON SOCIAL, FOLLOW ME, FOLLOW LIV
AND B/R BETTING.
I'M GREG IVORY.
WE'RE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.